allora ragazzi oggi è successa una cosa
strana è un punto del video dove io
ammazzo
la gente mi vede e non mirpò giuro
guardatevi da anzi lo lascio perché è
inutile che parlo
[Musica]
dai niente di già allora mi arriva
ranieri posta dallo stesso parlare non
posso parlare io
favi e vessicchio siamo entrati nello
stesso istante in inabile abbiamo
trovato un cadavere e nella ripresa
abbiamo avuto pure raga che hanno
coperto e li amo io li amo mi copro non
mi scoprono amico togliamo bellissimo
braga non si potè chiamato e l'avesse
degli concesso e marci che si chiama il
verde il giallo mi stanno supportando da
morire e mi hanno visto uccidere già
incredibile mi hanno visto uccidere
messi che march mi hanno visto uccidere
gli averi che mi seguono tutti e due
qui stanno seguendo bellissimo uccidere
verità vigili stata data alla stata
trattata vedeva dove si chiuderà il 6
nel secchio vessicchio venite qua che lo
ammazzo venite
eccolo noche fair eccepire se fermi non
si può uccidere nessuno cep e recepire
ok aspetta fermi fermi c'è una porta
step quindi lasciatemi vivo grazie
grazie succedendo anche se è morto roba
allora io stavo per rientrare in
electric all mi si sono chiuse le porte
di pronte ma prima che si chiudessero
visto il tastino del report tuo bacio è
morto qualcuno ma eravate tutti liberi
raga secondo me c'è il bug di navigation
della ricorre ne va però ragazzi eravate
tutti lì dentro infatti io ho visto io
ho messo io fa vi avessi che ormai è
tipo un accordo non scritto stiano
sempre vicini io
raga io non sono non meno facile non è
alla prossima
io ripeto secondo me si fanno mai bene
mi sono mai niente per yacht race tech
comunque guarda cambia nome lo vedo
partita partita dai libri che ormai
marcio che si chiami spalleggia marce
che si chiami spalleggiare io entro
nelle mense ti seguo 36 maledetto dove
sei
eccolo qua
mannaggia a lui risulta scrive ragala
tasse
una vittoria una vittoria incredibile ma
perché ce l'ha solo il costare ovvero io
a fare la tasca
il ragazzo è successo che davanti aveva
i siti ne uccide uno sia così com'è ha
ucciso senza motivo e quindi siete tutti
alleati
io ho aspettato un non so cosa succedeva
dentro ci sono riuscito ce lo uccido
entrano vessicchio
non ho esitato un attimo a loro ha detto
buffett invece bella kate
i ragazzi di oggi che spaccano tutto
ragazzi dobbiamo riuscire a fare fuori
che noia che l'impostore che partecipano
da un insieme di marce che noia secondo
kumar ci sta dando poi non si fa la
tasca se non fa niente la sta facendo la
sta facendo va bene dai allora forse non
è ma ci sarebbe stato troppo fabbricare
bene perché ficcare mette sempre un dito
nell'anno ragazzi chi fa i camera nel
solito la perde quindi
ora ho fatto una giocata da 2 mila e o
non è lui non avrebbe senso
ok come aver visto un impostore fuori
dal mio figlio allora electrical my boys
a tutte le tasche di elettrica allora o
dio hanno messo le stelline
[Musica]
ma per i daltonici non sono serio perché
mi sa che per riconoscere meglio i
colori ha messo le stelline
ecco i quadri hanno fatto una patch di
quattro mega prima di essere il suo
video ho notato questa cosa quindi mi sa
proprio che per quel motivo il buon
vessicchio
quindi hanno messo le stelline per
riconoscere dei casi è giusto allora la
moglie ragazzi navigatore in weapons il
genere mischia milano fuori però march
non è qui rimane of march che non è mar
ci sono quasi sicuro che non sia un dio
quanta gente ragazzi ma nessuno sta
facendo le tasche perché lo vedo le
tasche ma perché non c'è la percentuale
di completamento delle tasche di porco
demonio bruttissimo così anche adesso
cioè praga a c'è solo questo per gli ha
fatto io allora mi dice di sì posso
dirti vestiti prima che lo dici l'hai
trovato in caffetteria aspetta vediamo
vediamo
sono salito a fare una missione dei cavi
colloqui in caffetteria ho visto martina
che si avvicinava poi ha visto
chiaramente se n'è andato io me ne sono
andata è morto loco dico solo questo ma
insomma io posso dire questa è pulito
per arrivare comunque io
sembrava perché ho visto il tuo
personaggino marchi ha detto mi sembra
un buon richiamo bedi mi hai rotto
marino 6 della forza che ne so chi sei
tu margherita in tasca
questa volta l'ha votata io che noi è
stato perché la voto sempre le tasche
che mi mancano solo due e quindi
veramente siamo vincendo la stragrande
morto solo una persona quindi oi killer
si muovono adesso ci sono trenta secondi
di di free time quindi veramente sono
siamo messi benissimo se ci muoviamo con
in tasca abbiamo vinto
ci sono stati lentissimi che noi a
uccidere è stata lentissima perché che
noi ovviamente io già l'ho scoperta non
c'è neanche bisogno regalo sappiamo che
che noi lo sappiamo
io faccio l'ultima mia task 123 e quale
mamma mia bijoux e deroga
speriamo che qualcuno chi è qua che sta
telecamere marcianò ok per a charlie
watts
oddio delibori venga marce ucciso
chiacchiera stissi certo alla io sono
marci ha ucciso in atto davanti a meri
ragazzi votate me va bene mercoledì con
il ragazzo ma non posso parlare
stavo andando solo andando a farle
emergenza perché avevo le telecamere
attive martin ha preso la botta
navigation guarda martiti volevo capire
e ti voleva coprire ma mi ha incolpato
senza lettera aironi da ha ucciso nat
radio mi fido di marcia chiamarci si
guarda a una domanda che tipo la domanda
aspetta non avevi un elmetto prima
esatto esatto superiori e li metto in
testa dentro
playstation 5 melo simon tanto il
maestro stefano ha cambiato il titolare
se per questo non ho giocate stesso
sperimenta celestino va bene ma latina
nel dubbio tanto mi sono preso tutti
bene ma se sei tu
marcella ucciso davanti a me però ancora
di me a prescindere come sempre meno
male che che si vede se chiedi impostor
quella che siano le martina sanità in
automatico ai ragazzi sempre bello
giocare anch'io riposata marcelline però
tutti avete avuto una martina di aprire
non uccidere le persone davanti agli
altri ragazzi stefano ragazzi vi giuro
stef aveva le volevo dirlo io ve lo
giuro volevo dirlo io stesso avevo un
elemento gli sparito l'elmetto a steve
sparito l'elmetto
hai visto dallo stesso giocatore spero
che adesso prevedere se aveva una skin
nuova cambiano la ragazza secondo me è
un bug non è colpa di stefano rajola
cambiare allora niente sarà cambiato
guardami ha ucciso la cosa come io
maggioranza non ho parole stazza vedo
marano impossibile non ha le skin già a
troppe scheme tutte in una piazza la
carta igienica facciamo ancora poiché
come va che abbia spinto la partita lo
puoi cambiare le skin stef cambia
vestiti
soffre la voglio fare una pa una killer
o no certo ho capito però io come faccio
ma martinica qualche misera mi aspetta
che parla ti vogliamo coprire i ragazzi
ringrazio marci e passate anche ad
arrivarci perché è salvato ma grazie
anche avessi io che le leo che mi ha
dato la mano in 3d grazie a tutti i
ragazzi supportati costruito
maggiormente mi piace e mi chiede a
cagare ovviamente noi ci vediamo come
sempre hanno seguito da boys
[Musica]